michael is with us in detroit hey
michael how are you
i'm welcome to you how are you doing
today sir better than i deserve
how can we help so
i'm um i'm very thankful and fortunate
for on that um
i've saved and scrimped a lot in my life
and
i have a pretty good savings and i
grew up in a very very poor household
and it was homeless for a while
and i'm debt free and i'm too concerned
that i'm not
maximizing what i could be doing um
my goal really is to leave behind some
generational wealth for my children
um but i'm pretty uh nervous when it
comes to real estate
especially i've been listening to a lot
of folks for their their homes you know
people aren't being forced to pay their
rent and then
the people that own these properties are
you know losing them so i'm just looking
for some guidance
on what someone in my position could do
i'm sorry what to do with what you want
you want to build generational wealth
and people are losing their houses
because they don't pay rent i don't
i don't understand yeah so so look for
for a better investment so
you know right now i'm maxing out my
401k to the
legal limit and i've got some um i've
got some you know investments in some
mutual funds
but i'm not really especially uh assumed
i guess in investing
um and so i'm i know that you speak a
lot about real
estate um but i was wondering if you
just had any guidance on
you know how to how to maximize um
returns if you're a little skittish on
on real estate
okay i um if you're asking what to
invest in
number one all investments have a level
of risk
period and that means there's unknowns
that means things are going to happen
that you can't predict
and that are going to that obviously if
you knew
a negative thing was going to happen you
would not be in that investment we all
would
avoid that that's obvious but there are
all
all every single investment has a risk
okay now let's start with like a savings
account you could open a cd
and make one percent on your money and
you don't have any risk
oh yes you do wait all investments have
risk
what's the risk of having making one
percent on your money well we just
talked about a minute ago inflation runs
four percent
4.2 and taxes are going to take
a fifth of what you make a fourth of
what you make a third of what you make
okay and so you gotta make six but
you're only making one
and so you are losing five percent a
year in purchasing power
when you save money at one percent so
you just picked a risk
a an investment that you thought had no
risk and you pretty much guaranteed a
loss
in purchasing power okay so that one
doesn't work that's one end of the
spectrum the other end of the spectrum
is doing high risk things
where you lose all the money and you
play you know you go to the roulette
table
or you play bitcoin or you play gold
or you play uh you know you bet football
or i don't know whatever you want to
call these things that are they're
gambling
in essence and you hope that you hit
and you think that you're the exception
and you're gonna hit and we don't do
that one either
so what we do play in is in the middle
uh and in the middle i found two things
that i'm comfortable with the risk
and with the returns and that's real
estate which has some risk the renter
may not pay
the house may burn down it may get
flooded a tornado may hit it a tree may
fall across it
um some government agency may lose their
dead gum
mind and decide covet means that they
have the right to take over the freaking
world
oh wait that just happened and so uh you
know and they shut down
you know i had a guy in one of our
properties who was beating his wife
drinking and tearing up everything had
nothing to do with covid
it had to do with he's an idiot and we
couldn't get him out because they had a
moratorium on evictions because of covet
in tennessee that's been lifted thank
god and we got we tossed that piece of
trash out
um bless his little wife's heart you
know
oh god what a mess and so you know but
this is a risk of owning real estate
and people say well i buy real estate
renters will always pay
anything about renters so uh you know
some do some don't and you do your best
just like not all employees work hello
and so
um this is these are risks you take so
you assess the risk versus the return
and you accept the risk pretty much know
you're going to have some of it
and that goes with the returns and if
you measure that out that's what wealthy
people do
and so i buy real estate and accept the
risk and i love the returns i buy mutual
funds and i accept the risk
and i don't and i look for the returns i
don't buy single stocks
a valid investment but too much risk for
me
but versus the return i get i i've been
broke and i don't need to lose my money
and so i don't put all my money or a
bunch of my money in one company
uh although had you put it in apple you
would have done well had you put it in
microsoft you would have done well
but i don't do that i've got friends
that have done all kinds of single stock
investments and
it's like a fishing story they always
talk about the one they catch right they
talk about on the golf course right oh
sure
and they always got a story so but it's
a risk analysis
michael that's what you learn to get
used to there is no
formula where you don't take risk and
you make money
doesn't exist yeah it just comes down to
how much risk you're willing to take and
again i want to dive a little deeper on
that because i know that advice and i've
heard you give it many many times
you're not saying that it's it's wrong
to do but it's just really really risk
and you've learned over time
with your track record of investing and
the appetite that you had for risk
coming out of getting
debt free i'm just not going to play
that game it's not worth it
and that's that's really what what we
need to hear i mean you could certainly
invest
in a single stock but you got to be on
top of it or you lose your shirt you got
to really know what you're doing
i mean i could take 10 000 and put a
slot machine right
but i just don't i just don't like the
payout probability and that's really
important
yeah and uh but that doesn't mean that
doesn't
you know doesn't mean you sometimes you
don't hit on a slot machine right but
i'll guarantee you i do know who hits on
the slot machine
yeah the casino oh yeah they make money
on them every day
yep no one else does yeah so i mean you
start to learn these games and you go
that's the game this is going to miss
the game so i'm going to measure the
risk versus the return
and i'm going to accept the risk to get
the return
and if you don't take enough risk you
get tackled from behind by inflation and
taxes
if you take too much risk you you lose
your money
i'm going to ask you this when you
invest into real estate of course now
you're
paying cash here so we're talking about
cash investing in real estate
what are the risk meters you run through
before you buy a house that you're going
to rent
what are you looking at are you looking
at neighborhood of course you look i
mean what are some of the things that
people need to think through
well the first lens we look at is you
make your money on the buy right
and so is it a bargain mm-hmm which
there's nine bargains right now right
the market's quite hot you're not a
steel you know we bought a lot of
foreclosures we bought a lot of stuff in
2008 when the market went down all that
but there's no there's no bargains in
real estate right now so i'm not buying
real estate right now i'm building some
but i'm not buying any
um and so uh the thing is the
um you know i'm looking at the bargain
on the front end
that helps me yeah because that lowers
your risk then so if you've got a
property that's worth
300 000 and you pay 180 for it
you just limited your risk yes and now
then obviously you got to look at the
property and go
is this marketable i mean if it's a
weird
twisted up floor plan that's not
rentable or resellable
then there's a reason it was a bargain
it sucks right
you know so you just gotta gotta use
some common sense and go
somebody walks up to this or they're
gonna wanna rent it somebody walks up to
this later and i wanna sell it are they
gonna wanna stop by
and so we're looking at the curb appeal
the quality of the property the location
of the property
um you know you know and and then what
are we going to rent it for
what's the rental market versus what we
pay for it and that's your return on
investments a fairly simple equation
and so but it is a lot of common sense
that's why it's good to buy real estate
in your area because you
inherently intrinsically know the area